[Music]
joining me today is a sex researcher a
neuroscientist and co-host of the wrong
speak podcast dr. Deborah so welcome to
the Rubin report hi I am glad to have
you here finally I'm so happy to be here
all right we got a lot to talk about I
thought the best way to start this thing
I don't like to look at my notes upfront
but you had a line on your patreon page
that I thought summed up the whole damn
thing pretty perfectly your patreon bio
says creating journalism that defends
science and free speech you've come to
the right show all right I think so yeah
okay should we talk about sex first
should we just start with sex and then
cuz it's all gonna it all bleeds into
one thing definitely yeah okay you
started as a neuroscientist
but you were sort of more attracted for
a lack of a better word to studying sex
tell me about that yeah so I mean I
decided to go back to school and do my
PhD in neuroscience and along the way I
had the chance to do a placement in
psychology so I'd never heard of sex
research before I had no idea what it
was but it was so fascinating to me and
I thought it's crazy that we have the
technology to look at people's brains
and look at sexual arousal in the brain
and it tells us so much about what it
means to be human so from from there I
was hooked I loved it my PhD was in
using brain imaging to look at
paraphilias which are a typical sexual
interest and hyper sexuality in men and
I love research I always will but I made
the decision to leave academia and work
full-time as a journalist now because
the climate had changed so much even
between when I started my PhD and when
it when I finished yeah and that's why
the stuff that you're talking about
really is a nexus of everything that I'm
doing here because now you're on the
journalist side but it's because of the
hostility that you were facing on the
academic side so what worried what is it
that you were unearthing or studying
that was so triggering to people HM well
within psychology you can't really study
anything that isn't triggering it's
across the board someone's gonna get mad
at you no matter what but even though
you're really looking at facts you're
look you're you're looking to find
yeah exactly and even with brain imaging
I mean that's that's definitely it's a
growing feel the technology is
legitimate but no matter what I think
because sex is still considered very
taboo people will either project their
own ideas and beliefs and values onto it
or they just don't see the value and
they think why is the government funding
this I feel really lucky being in Canada
we do have a pretty amazing scene in
terms of sex research and my colleagues
do manage to get funding so I think
that's excellent but my decision to
leave academia in the last two years I
had noticed things were starting to go a
bit weird and in terms of the climate
and in terms of mainstream media I was
seeing piece after piece about
transgender kids and how young children
were socially transitioning getting on
blockers pubertal blockers and the media
is basically saying this is the greatest
thing this is something that we should
rejoice about that these kids are so
much better off after but from a
scientific perspective the research
actually shows that the majority of kids
who are gender dysphoria grow their
feelings they're more likely to grow up
to be gay in adulthood not transgender
and so it makes sense for them to wait
not for them to socially transition at a
young age so I wanted to write a
mainstream piece about this and there's
been a very long-standing history
between trans activists and sex
researchers a very ugly history of
activists going after sex researchers if
they don't like what some one study says
or what they say publicly so I thought
about it for a long time I wrote the
piece and I sat on it probably for about
six months and I wasn't sure if I wanted
to put it out I asked a bunch of my
colleagues and mentors and they all said
you know what the science is solid but
you know you know what's gonna happen if
you do put this out and at the time I
wanted to stay in academia and I said
should I wait till I get tenure and
everyone told me even if you have tenure
nowadays it's not going to protect you
you can still lose your job so I decided
eventually I couldn't stay quiet and I
thought I'm not going to stay in an
environment where I can't speak the
truth and I can't even pursue questions
that are meaningful anymore because I
have to worry about who's gonna get mad
and then I'm gonna lose my money and my
funding and I'm gonna lose my job so
that piece went out it's called white
transgender kids show a way to
transition and
and I haven't looked back since yeah so
I reread I've read the piece before but
I reread it this morning thank you I got
here and there's a lot here so how much
of this is just blade is just blatantly
a misunderstanding of science like I
think there's partly that you have a
misunderstanding of science and then you
just have activists who just want you to
bow to them all the time are you able to
sort of quantify how much of the
backlash is each I think should be
charitable I try to look at the other
side and give them you know credit and
try to you know think that they have
good intentions
maybe people I mean it's pretty
consistent all 11 studies ever done on
the topic of desist in so this
phenomenon I talked about where kids
grow out of their feelings of gender
dysphoria all of them say the same thing
so the final statistic is about 60 to 90
percent so this is the vast majority of
kids you can't really question those
data so I think what it could be is
people I mean trans people have a
history of having you do of medical
gatekeeping of people telling them they
don't really what they feel isn't real
I do think gender dysphoria is a real
phenomenon and I do think we should have
empathy for people who are suffering so
I think it could be coming from that of
that place of well we don't want people
saying that this isn't a legitimate
thing or that trans people should be
forced to not feel the way they do but
in terms of you know these children we
should be thinking about the best
outcome so it doesn't make sense for
them to transition if that's not
actually going to help them in the long
term I try to give people the benefit
the doubt but I do think the activists
they on some level I think they know
that they can bully sex researchers
because of that history they know that
there's only so much an academic can do
and they've won a couple battles so I
think that's part of it as well
how shocking was it to you when you were
discussing this with colleagues that
they were kind of hinting you may want
to wait on this thing I mean did you
think that you'd be in that situation
and I'm wondering did any of them sit on
some other things because they were
afraid to hmm it was eye-opening yeah
but I kind of knew one
one I guess instance I can talk about is
one colleague Michael Bailey at
Northwestern University he wrote a book
that upset transgender activists and
they went off after him ruthlessly I
mean they really tried to destroy his
life and thankfully you know he's he's
still considered one of the foremost
experts in psychology internationally
but I would say that you know I've
written about him previously I think
he's kind of been the poster boys to why
people are really terrified to say
anything that goes against the trans
narrative yeah so I think you've already
hinted at this and I know your work
otherwise but so you have no issue with
trans people as people just to be clear
this is purely about the science related
to transitioning and hormone blockers
and things of that nature of a certain
age where they're doing it as young as I
think you're right about 14 right oh
younger than that now well yeah I mean
if there's parental consent definitely
and I have to say for transgender adults
and I say even kids who reach puberty
and still feel that way I think
transitioning is is totally up to you if
that's what the path you decide to go
then power to you I don't think there's
any ones penny it's anyone's business to
tell you what to do at that point so a
lot of their basic parameters related to
age then well there are in terms of I
don't work with children I don't do
clinical work anymore but in terms of
the research literature usually
clinicians will wait until puberty and
see how the child feels at that time
when the body starts changing when they
start having crushes on their peers and
that kind of thing and the research does
show that when kids start to you know
have crushes and start dating and that
can play a role in terms of how they
feel about their bodies and whether they
do outgrow it but just at that point
your whole body is in flux your mental
states and flux your physical states and
flux and as you said what did you say a
percentage on that of how many of them
turn out to just they generate so yeah
so they so sixty to ninety percent of
the the children undergoing these
feelings turn out to be gay and then I
assume the ones that don't transition
probably most of them end up being okay
with being gay I would imagine
roughly yeah and I would say even I grew
up in the gay community I have a lot of
gay male friends and they've said to me
when I was young I told my parents all
the time
hated being a boy and I wanted to be a
girl and I am a girl and why can't I
become a girl and now as a gay man I'm
so comfortable I'm so happy and they say
to me you know I'm kind of glad I'm not
growing up in this time because I think
I probably would have transitioned yeah
well that's why the the external
pressure seems so crazy to me because
you just don't know at that at that age
and even if you do know waiting a little
bit isn't gonna for the science to flesh
out it's not that's not gonna kill you
it's just hard talking about this even
you know yeah I mean the thing is what
people also aren't talking about is that
for these kids so in some cases the
parents don't want a gay child and this
is what upsets me the most so if you
have a little boy who's very feminine
he's likely gonna grow up to be a gay
man but if you take that same Lavoie and
allow him to transition to female when
he grows up he's gonna appear to be a
straight woman and so these parents are
being lauded as progressive when really
they're homophobic God how perverse that
is that's interesting what you just said
about a certain amount of gay men that
grow up you know they wanted to be or
felt more like a girl or whatever and
that eventually grow out and we were
okay
because I never felt that like I played
sports and I played video games and
transformers all all the things that my
friends did I never felt like I was a
girl or more effeminate people always
say to me I don't seem gay I'm always
like I don't know what that you know I
didn't mean like I'm married to a guy
yeah I mean that's pretty gay but I
never had that but that's that's sort of
just interesting about the psychology Oh
gay people in general there are gay
people that grow up feeling very
effeminate or gay men that grow up not
feeling that way and I'm sure there's
women that grow up feeling very butch or
whatever and there's women that grow up
that are you know lipstick lesbians yeah
and the whole thing have you done any
research on it on any of that in terms
of my research no but in terms of what
studies have shown it is about hormone
levels in utero
so testosterone if you are exposed to
higher levels of testosterone in utero
you're more likely to be male typical in
masculine when you're born so whether
you're male or female so most boys are
exposed to high levels of testosterone
so that explains when they're born why
they are interested in male typical toys
and activities so for gay men they were
likely exposed to lower levels of
testosterone which is why
they're more feminine and the same with
with girls if they're exposed to higher
levels of testosterone they're more
likely to be masculine and lesbian right
even though there's obvious outliers
this is on average on average anna is is
there danger in talking about that
because I would imagine that the certain
amount of people in the gay community
that would want you to never go down
that road because then you could end up
in a place where oh we would be able to
prevent people from being hey ultimately
if we can really figure out the science
behind all this definitely and I mean as
a straight woman I have to say I even
iron right now feel like maybe I
shouldn't be saying these things because
I'm not gay I can't speak for the a
community but as a former sex researcher
I am very much a proponent of I'd rather
you speak researcher that a gay person
or a straight person or anything else I
mean this this is the problem though
you're you know to be like you're an
expert in this and it's like even for
you who's so brave on all of these
issues it gets weird to talk about it
even for me I just it's like a little
weird to talk about you feel like a
traitor no I I am what I am and that's
all that I am that's it but like I know
that just even talking about this just
gets people crazy and I know what our
what our Twitter feeds are gonna look
like yeah you get ready so I mean it's
crazy because even my colleagues who
have the best intentions they're doing
this research because they just want to
understand why are people the way they
are it's not there are no nefarious
intentions there but people are so quick
to jump on I mean there was earlier this
year that there was a study about using
AI to be able to detect whether someone
is gay by looking at their face and so
again studies have shown that on average
you can see differences between straight
and gay people both men and women in
terms of facial features and so
everyone's freaking out about this study
and I'm thinking why aren't we saying
this is amazing that we are able to know
this and I mean I think I've really good
gaydar I've always thought I have and
now I think great like there's actually
some quantitative data to suggest that
I'm not just making things up right and
they're also they always say well gay
guys have gaydar there's something else
that maybe you can see or whatever it is
or though they're I don't know the
people say it anymore but he was just a
gay face like there was just something
about the facial features sometime
of gay men maybe they were a little
softer or whatever it is I don't even
know what it is but like people were
talking about that in the gay community
then it comes out through some sort of
science lens and it's like ooh we better
watch out for that and the thing is then
researchers see that and say well I
don't want to go through that so then
they don't want to touch that topic so
now there's they're eventually going to
be only like two different things you
can probably study unless you know that
what your findings what you're going to
find is going to be politically
acceptable in which case you shouldn't
be doing the research because that means
you're not actually doing science yeah
what do you think it is about you that
makes you brave enough to do this sort
of thing because I've had a couple other
people we're going to talk about James
the more in a little bit cuz you've also
written about him and and why the whole
thing about diversity and all that but
I've had a bunch of outliers in these
communities on the show and I'm always
curious what it is about the specific
people that make them sort of put it out
there and go I'm gonna do it whether you
like it or not it's probably my
personality yeah I mean I just generally
don't really care what people think
about me and I'm pretty stubborn and I
I'm very I feel very strongly about sex
research being taken seriously and my
decision to have gone and gone into that
field you deal with a lot of stigma as I
mentioned earlier you deal with it on
both sides you know and when you make
the decision to go into the field
suddenly when people know what you do
they will judge you on a personal level
so I think that was part of it you know
I grew a very thick skin from saying I'm
gonna do what I find interesting people
can assume whatever they want about me
and that I think that just translated
into now what I do as a science
journalist but this I would say to and
I'm sure you probably went through a
similar experience once you speak out it
becomes much easier and I find I can't I
can't stay quiet now and I find the
people that are gonna you know turn
their backs on you let them because you
don't need them in your life yeah once
you start you just you can't stop
actually yeah if it's built into you you
just can't stop so one of the things I
think is really interesting is how you
know there's there's such a movement
always to say that gay people are born
this way right Lady Gaga even wrote a
song about war in this way party Gaga
yeah and yet at the same time if I know
for a fact like I have a friend who for
many years was my lesbian friend
one good lesbian friend and she was you
know datin girls all the time and all
that then about three years ago we were
sitting there and she told me that she
met a guy and now she's been with this
guy for about three or four years and
they're getting married and she
identifies basically as bisexual now but
she's only she's exclusively been with a
guy for about four years but what I find
interesting about it is that her lesbian
friends have basically all turned on her
and this is supposed to be that these
are supposed to be the people of
tolerance and we should accept your
sexuality and all that but when it goes
the other way suddenly it becomes this
other thing have you have you seen that
before I suspect you hey I can imagine
that I'm guessing they probably think
that she sold out they think she's a
sellout yeah yeah you're taking the easy
road or something like that like every
insane cliche and I know her to be
completely authentic and real how does
how has she dealt with it I'm curious
it's been well it's woken her up in a
zillion other ways so for a lot of the
other things that that we talked about
about free speech and politics and
freedom and all that she started to wake
up to all of that she was a huge lefty
progressive and now she's basically a
libertarian because she saw that
authoritarian thing why do you guys want
to control me yeah the second I think
differently you guys want to control me
yeah so now she's like the locust of all
of my friends so to speak that's the
thing I think all of us are eventually
gonna have a moment like that where you
realize what you thought was the truth
is not the truth and there there's so
many other things it's like falling down
that rabbit hole in real and you start
to question everything then and it's
really liberating but you know in terms
of sexuality that's I mean that's very
common women female sexuality is much
more fluid than men so men tend to be
very category specific if you're into
women you really like women and you're
not two guys if you're into guys -
really guys not women and then women
tend to be a little bit more flexible
it's like you find you know there are
mostly straight married men that on the
DL are sleeping with other guys but I'm
pretty sure there aren't many gay men
that are in relationships are married
that are sneaking out and sleeping with
women know on the DL have you ever seen
one of those in your research okay
there's gotta be right
you know I think the first case I think
is probably closeted gays and then the
second case I have to think about that
right but you're a closeted gay well I
guess you might be sleeping yeah I mean
I did it like I slept with women as sort
of like an overcompensation or I was
trying it's not even over compensation I
was really trying I just thought I
should try and I tried and you know
eventually I tried no more yeah I think
also for gay men when you come out it's
such a big thing and I think to make
that decision to come out is really
committing to this as much as you know
we don't like identity labels it is an
identity label so I would see it as
being less common for someone who's gay
to be sleeping with women on the side
because he would have likely just stayed
in that camp right that would be my
guess
yes okay so you mentioned that you you
study a lot of this related to the brain
how a lot of this is sort of built into
us and you study this across sort as
fetishes the right word paraphilias yeah
yeah fetish is a specific paraphilia but
across the board basically kinky people
yeah it's a way what's the definition of
paraphilia
unusual sexual interests and has that
different than fetish well fetish is a
specific object or body part that you
have a preference for got it so so let's
talk about a couple of those okay there
are a lot of them so I always I tell
people this and no one ever believes me
but I'm actually very very traditional
vanilla and not kinky but I love it
gonna ask you all that at the end about
yourself pretty much but okay yeah but I
mean I I find it super fascinating and I
guess that's my way of living
vicariously you know so in terms of
different paraphilias I mean there's
voyeurism soap you know known as peeping
tom exhibitionism so people like to
expose themselves sadism and masochism
which are different from BDSM so BDSM is
consensual masochism and sadism so
masochism being wanting wanting to be
humiliated sadism is one just your
partner being humiliated BDSM is very
much about consent so it's not true
masochism or sadism because partners
will negotiate beforehand and not do
anything outside
of particular boundaries and that kind
of thing what else is there
FRA tourism so it's when people like to
rub up against unsuspecting people there
tons I could go on forever mm-hmm yeah
and so how are these all connected to
the same parts of the brain is it the
same men mechanism that's working and
the fetish itself is just manifested in
a different targets yeah so with my
research when I was still a researcher I
found that for men who are kinky when
they look at kinky pornography the same
brain network activates as when non
kinky people are looking at regular or
vanilla pornography so it suggests that
paraphilia is maybe akin to a sexual
orientation so that's not to say that's
the same as being gay but it's the same
idea conceptually that it's someone's
preference it can't be changed and it's
with them from from very early on yeah
how does the internet play into all this
because I know you've you've written
about porn addiction and yeah things
like that where now all of this stuff is
so accessible where obviously I've been
15 20 years ago it's a lot more looking
for it yeah I think people are probably
able to test out different things and go
searching for things out of curiosity
but if you really like something I don't
think it's because you happen to find it
on the internet and with porn addiction
in particular there's no research to
suggest that it's a real thing that
excessive porn viewing is akin to an
addiction usually if you talk to someone
with problems with porn
across the board it's there's always
some other reason why either they're
anxious they like to procrastinate or
they don't like to procrastinate but
they use it as a way of procrastinating
and avoiding other things it's not that
they're actually addicted to pornography
right so when you hear those that people
will say well you're getting that
dopamine yeah isn't that partly what
being addicted you wouldn't you become
addicted to that well my understanding
the term addiction slightly incorrectly
that's true but dopamine is released
during the number of different things if
you eat a nice piece of food that you
like dopamine is released if you see a
nice picture dopamine stress I mean it's
reward but it's responsible for a lot of
different things so I think that's one
case of I mean I do have some issue with
science journalists watering things down
and liking to take one finding or one
study and kind of you know representing
it or mister
presenting it so it's not really an
accurate take on it but I understand why
people think that because dopamine has
been seen as the the addiction
neurotransmitter and you see so much
about porn addiction sex addiction I
would say probably a year ago it was
everywhere everyone was talking about
porn addiction and sex addiction even
though there again there's no legitimate
research to suggest either of those
things are real hmm so when you've
studied all of these things what are
what are you finding out about the brain
as a neuroscientist and can anything be
done for any of these things if somebody
was are taking in these things and
either didn't want to or at least wanted
to understand it or whatever else the
biggest thing I would say is find a
partner who accepts you for who you are
because whatever you're into especially
for men it's not going to change and so
the difference between someone who has
meaning women's kinks or whatever will
change with time where a man would be
less than quite I do yeah the same with
you know in the same way with the sexual
orientation women tend to be more
flexible with their sexual preferences
so if they're kinky they might be really
kinky with one partner or if they have a
partner who's very kinky they might be
into whatever he's into if it's a
straight couple
but then if she's with someone who's
less kinky might not be as much of a
problem whereas if it's a man who's
really into something if his partner's
not into it he's always going to be into
it he's just gonna have to hide it yeah
have you heard of this phrase lesbian
bed death um oh I'm all over the place
I'm just going into the fall to come up
with yeah by have you heard this phrase
before it means that there's no sex
after a certain amount of time yeah that
lesbians it sort of burns very hot for
that early period and then the u-haul
shows up in a joke and then just like
the desire for sex just disappears just
lots of cuddling yeah yeah I have heard
of that well men on average do tend to
have a higher sex drive so I could see
if you're in a relationship where it's
two women how this you know their sex
drive might be a bit lower not sure what
else like if not anything else all right
what what are you really thinking about
right now right
in general what are the the topics that
are really on your mind related to all
this my concern number one is probably
seeing how gender is being warped to
facilitate particular political agendas
as you mentioned James two more and
seeing how that whole thing unfolded
last summer okay so let's talk about
could you wrote a piece on it I remember
the piece coming out I did yeah so I
remember when that news first broke that
this sexist memo was going around and I
read it and I thought okay this is not
sexist and then I saw the statement from
Google that he was perpetuating gender
stereotypes and I thought oh no and so I
wrote that column for The Globe and Mail
to speak to the science and say you know
what the science that James cited was
absolutely 100% legitimate and there
shouldn't be anything wrong with saying
that and if you actually read his memo
you'll see that he's not a misogynist
and we actually so the podcast that I
co-host with Jonathan Kaye called wrong
speak we actually interviewed him for
our first episode and if you listen to
him speak you can see I mean he's very
much for equality between the sexes he
says that if men and women don't talk to
each other that's gonna harm both of us
but it was much easier for them to paint
him as a misogynist and as an alt right
figure because I guess you know there's
nothing else going on the news did you
feel that the article or at least when
James was able to get out there and say
what he thought whether he did it here
or on Rogan or a series of other
podcasts did you feel that that was able
to break through to some of the people
that it needed to break through to like
I know it gets to the masses right it
gets to the people who appreciate maybe
what happens in here or on Rogan or
things like that but for any of the
people that really need to hear it the
ones that are at Google or the ones that
are setting the diversity agenda at
schools and all that is there any sign
that any of this push back against it
has taken root no I think it's gone
worse if anything honestly which is
terrible I think they are so set in that
mindset that you really can't you can't
say anything I think reasonable people
if you talk to them I was surprised
actually at that time because a lot of
people that I knew that were really
intelligent really rational had bought
into this narrative that he was a sexist
person who said that
women are biologically inferior and are
not capable of engineering or working in
tech and I said well why would you think
that did you read the memo and most
people had no idea but then because
left-wing media was so adamant about
this message people just assume well
they're not gonna lie why would they lie
and you know we are in this industry so
of course we know but I think most
people just take a face value they're
busy they have their jobs and so they
see a headline or they see an interview
they just think well I like a mainstream
interview they think well they wouldn't
be saying these things if there wasn't
some truth to them but no they're
blatantly lying they're blatantly lying
has all of this and being part of this
and now you know being very public about
your opinions has this changed your
politics at all I find that it
consistently has changed people's
politics usually it ships people to more
of what I would say is a classical
liberal position but what a libertarian
just more of a less government position
as you want because that's where I think
at the moment the most freedom lays yeah
I would agree with that and especially
the idea of the government I used I used
to be definitely more left much much
more left I would still call myself a
liberal but definitely now that I see
because I used to think was good for the
government to come in and help people
and to kind of set the tone but now now
I'm seeing things that are not hate
speech or being considered hate speech
and genuine facts were not allowed to
say them anymore so I'm much more
skeptical now of government intervention
of policies dictating what people can
and cannot do or say so I would say I
have moved more to the right but I would
still call myself a liberal and I mean
the fact that I write about sex research
for a living is pretty left yeah you're
my kind of liberal so you're good to go
in here so one of the things that I
think is fascinating about all of what
we're talking about here is that it's
not just about gender and sex and
sexuality but this is also leaking into
all sorts of other things talking about
ethnicity and color of skin and all of
that you've written a bit about this I
have yeah I wrote about how university
applications in particularly Harvard has
been discriminating against Asians for
decades and to the point where Asians
when they apply to university will want
to hide
ethnicity in hopes of that that's going
to give them a fair chance of actually
getting into the school yeah so alright
so somebody that's watching this right
now that doesn't know about this they're
gonna go wait a minute
why would Harvard discriminate against
Asian people because apparently there
are too many Asians there if it's based
solely on SAT scores and meritocracy
there's a very high proportion of Asian
students and so in the name of
quote-unquote diversity and inclusion
Asian students get penalized so this to
me is the most blatant example of why
this diversity stuff is complete
nonsense because people are face value
it seems nice we want to help people we
want to help groups that maybe have
struggled more for whatever reason I
think we should and and there's probably
many good ways to do that maybe
investing in more education or whatever
else I'm happy to hear your thoughts on
that but what they take as a good
thought then they don't think all the
way through which means okay now we're
gonna have to punish people who have
worked very hard and done everything
right and by and large the Asian
community whether it's Chinese or
Japanese or Korean or whatever else have
worked really hard and put a focus on
education and family and then what is
the result of that it's now harder if
not almost impossible at some level to
get into Harvard mmm-hmm and the
craziest thing I don't understand why
people think is this is acceptable and
even when I wrote that column I had a
number of Asians reach out to me and say
you know don't don't be used as a token
for the far right and I'm totally okay
with this this is fair and I'm thinking
you know what are you on I wasn't good
at the time to do an op-ed I think by an
Asian woman if I'm not mistaken
mm-hmm yeah saying that this is okay and
I just I mean what do you do we what do
you do it that you are fighting for true
equality yeah that is simply not what
they're fighting for
I think it's indoctrination at some
level I think especially for the kids
who are applying to these schools and
who are okay with having to score much
higher on the SAT in order to get a fair
chance I think they've just been told
you know this is how it has to be but
this idea that it should be equality
equality of outcome
as the poster opportunity is is silly
and it doesn't actually deal with actual
differences in terms of opportunity you
know in terms of the differences that we
see and the reasons why there are these
differences they're not actually being
addressed please tell me that you got
some nice support for members of the
Asian community and it wasn't just sort
of brainwashed lefties that were I
didn't know I didn't I got it across the
board of you know many races so I was
grateful for that because I wasn't sure
how people were going to respond to that
piece but I felt very strongly that I
had to say something has Harvard issued
a response to any of this or do we even
know where they're at with all this no
as far as I know that the lawsuit is
still ongoing yeah it's just it really
is just crazy so I are you with me on
this I sense that there's some massive
minority groups that are breaking right
now I think the Asian community because
of the I hate saying community but you
know you have to do some words to
describe some of this but I think the
black community is breaking this is what
a lot of what Candis Owens is talking
about I sense this happening in the gay
community I sense this happening in the
Jewish community on very similarly the
Asian community have hard work and an
education and all that so then you
decide we have to put you at the bottom
of the oppression Olympics so there's an
interesting like strange alliance now
now building up are you seeing that I
would say yeah I see it coming I see
well we were talking about the bit about
this earlier about how the left is gonna
eat its own until there is only one
person left so it's only a matter of
time really we're all gonna find each
other and say yeah we've had enough of
this I mean gay men you guys don't count
it doesn't count to be gay anymore so
and I never wanted extra credit I wanted
equality equality I wanted equal credit
not extra credit yeah so in a weird way
I'm actually okay being thrown out in
that regard of this pyramid because I
don't want to play that game but I think
actually finally some gay men especially
gay white men because now they're
they're fully thought of as the enemy I
mean I've even seen things on college
campuses where LGBT organizations are
saying well you can't be a gay white man
and be the president of the org
because you're you're one of the bad
guys I mean that that's really dangerous
thinking well I saw what you had to deal
with too with that professor who said
that the LGBT community doesn't want you
at the was at the University of
University of New Hampshire yeah do you
know that so I didn't know at the time
so I think much of my audience will know
what you're referring to but I spoke at
University of New Hampshire and there
were all these hecklers there and there
was a trans woman who I did not know was
a professor I didn't know that until
literally two months later who was was
screaming at me how much I hate trans
people all this and I kept saying I want
you to have equality under the law and I
want you to be treated with decency and
respect and I hope you find someone that
loves you all of the things I would want
for anyone else I just don't want the
government using dictating what pronouns
I can use to refer to you and you know
basically she was calling me all right
and all that and of course it turns out
she's a gender studies professor yeah I
should never be a surprise anymore
but there's gonna be no discipline at
the school or anything like that I mean
I could probably make more of a hey of
it and see what happens but it's like
yeah you know you handled it amazingly
well and works I mean it's only a matter
of time like I see with feminism they're
turning on white women now too so it's
insane is that the only logical outcome
of these disciplines because they are
not held to the scientific standard of
everything else that we discussed here
in the first half that you've that you
are held to as a scientist yeah I think
because everything is there's so much
based in subjective feeling and
validating people's experiences you
apparently can't question someone's
experience so if someone's offended or
they don't like you what can you say so
I could see that and it's it's very much
rewarding people for being emotionally
driven instead of I think the best way
to have a debate as to remove emotion
and just try to look at the facts as
objectively as you can no matter what
the issue is so it's that it's that they
don't really have any sort of method to
how they do their even their researches
I mean it's kind of a joke yeah but are
we kind of hearing that even the methods
now are part of the patriarchy and all
of those things you're using facts they
don't want facts to actually count
because they believe in this postmodern
drivel
that that facts have been arrived to by
mechanisms that they don't believe in
that's it that's a tough thing to trick
somebody out of yeah but you know I
think on some level I think some of
these scholars know that what they're
doing is very lucrative and so they're
just basically trying to shut people
down in any way they can they can't
really justify it but you know they just
keep screaming about it and academics
who have better things to do like
actually do real research and they've
got their courses and their students and
a million other things and they're
80-hour workweeks
they don't have time to deal with this
so this is why there's such a lopsided
discourse in terms of what you see
coming out of the universities and there
are some institutions that you know they
won't allow academics to engage with the
media without permission first so that
that's part of it too it's just it's
really an unfair battle right now that's
being fought yeah how do you think we
get to a place where specifically
related to sexuality and topics related
to gender and sex where we will be able
to talk about it in a in a better way so
for example the me2 movement where
everybody every I think basically
thinking person understands that there
were some really bad people here that
did some really bad stuff obviously
Harvey Weinstein and Bill Cosby and some
people that really that drugged people
and that you know years of history of
doing all this and then there's all
sorts of other people who seem like
they're just getting swept up in it or
baselessly accused or all that now you
can be for the idea of the me2 movement
without being for taking down all of
these other people also and I guess what
the real issue is is litigating
everyone's history where we could all
look back and go I did this someone did
that to me this that the other thing
college kids now have an assigned things
before they hook up I mean really where
we're creating this situation where our
interpersonal relations are gonna have
almost nothing to do with the stuff
that's hardwired into us that the stuff
that you study mm-hmm I think me too
probably started as something honorable
and I do agree that women and men have
been dealing with harassment for far too
long and that it doesn't get taken
seriously sometimes but it's to the
point now where relations are so
strained especially between men and
women
men are terrified and that's not going
to be helpful across the board for
anybody I think especially when you look
at shades of gray well I mean there's so
much I could say on this place to start
would be with consent say I think one
message that's been missing as women
I've written about this women need to
advocate for themselves and that's not
to say if you are experienced harassment
or if you were assaulted that you are at
fault I'm not advocating victim blaming
but I think what's missing from this
narrative women are portrayed as though
they're helpless and if something
happens to them they're helpless and
that they're basically they have no say
in terms of how men behave towards them
and you know I've written about sexism
in the sciences and how women are
basically being scared off I think of
going into the field as someone with a
PhD in a science field yeah you deal
with sexism and it's unpleasant but I
still got my degree and now I'm speaking
out about it so if you want to achieve
something you can as sexism it's not so
terrible in the world that women can't
achieve what they want so going back to
consent you know I think women need
young women especially you need to be
told you know you have a say in this if
you don't like something or if you don't
want to do something say so don't don't
feel like it's on the man - I don't read
your mind and I feel like I'm gonna get
in so much trouble for saying this but I
think that empowers women instead of
telling them you know just really hope
that this doesn't happen to you and if
it does then get on Twitter and use the
hashtag and talk about how men are
terrible and men are trashed men are not
terrible they're lovely men in the world
I love men you know there are some bad
men but you can't generalize to all men
yeah but we love the generalization
thing right I mean you even see this the
amount of articles where I see you know
we have to take down white it's always
white yeah we have to take down or or
now it's women's turn to rule the world
or all of these things and it's like
well a woman could be President or a
woman could be you know anything that a
man could be but it shouldn't be because
she's a woman it should be because she's
capable but but we've seen this sort of
astera
reaction to it and I think that that now
is just another one of these places
where we're on this crazy pendulum just
bouncing back and forth yeah I'm hoping
it's going to come back to the middle
and hopefully not too much damage will
be done before that happens and that the
you know relations between men and women
aren't going to be so terribly strained
I do think we're reaching that point
though because there are only so many
men left who haven't been accused of a
me-too moment so ya know it's only a
matter of time you know it's interesting
I have a running joke with some of my
friends that I know a lot of great
straight girls in LA that are single
mm-hmm a lot of straight great girls I
don't know a lot of straight guys that I
think are great like I know I know some
straight guys that are kinda whatever
but I don't know like a lot of straight
guys that kind of have their [ __ ]
together that are so I have all these
girls that are like oh can you set me up
with a guy and I'm like not guys I know
which does show that there's sort of a
crisis I think in masculinity or
something and obviously Jordan Peterson
is impressing this at some level
although now I've spent so much time
with him I think he's addressing it in a
certain way almost equally for men and
women although people only focus on the
male part but do you know is anyone
doing research on sort of what is
happening to young men in particular
right now hmm that's a good question I
know that levels of testosterone are
lower on average more recently so I
don't know if that has something to do
with it do we know what that what the
reasoning for that is could be maybe
there's more estrogens that are that
we're putting into our bodies trying to
think of what I can give you because
that that's an interesting so how old
are your friends I'm curious this sort
of set of friends that I'm talking about
these girls usually are in there sort of
like early 30s yeah kind of thing in
there and they're single which you know
most often cases a lot of them their
friends are married already
and like they're there on the hunt and
they've got good jobs and they look good
and they take care of themselves and all
of those things and I just don't see the
equivalent here mm-hmm
I don't maybe there's an odd subset of
because la is like a little bit of an
odd place maybe there's more gay people
here I don't know exactly yeah I mean I
could see the average age for people
getting married is 28 so I don't want to
I don't want to generalize
say that across what do you sciences
want to be fair yeah yeah but I mean it
could be that for guys who are a certain
age it there's a reason but at the same
thing for women of a certain age and not
to say love your friends of course but
you know if you're focused on your
career maybe you're not used to giving
your time to someone else that could be
part of it yeah yeah do you think that
the feminist movement which I know is
sort of we've sort of ancillary been
talking about it this whole time that
they really did give up something very
special by putting so much focus on work
and success in that way I mean you know
I think back to my childhood now which I
think in retrospect was so amazing my
mom was home for most of it she she
worked before I'm the oldest of three
she worked before I was there and then
she didn't work all the years that she
was raising us and then went back to
work after and that having someone at
home that was cooking and taking care of
us and making sure we got to school and
all those things
like that's like the greatest thing that
anyone could do it happens to more often
be the woman but that's a that's a
pretty great thing that's often been
sacrificed now we're thought of it's
mocked in a way now yeah I mean I've
always been a typical in terms of I've
always been felt more masculine and I've
always been very focused in my career
but I definitely think that feminism and
for some people or some proponents of
feminism they will denigrate female
typical roles and motherhood and wanting
to be you know at home with your family
and I think you know I've heard from
women who say I've been told that the
path to happiness is for me to focus on
my career and to neglect my personal
life and and then they reach a point
where they realize no I do want those
things and I don't think there should be
anything wrong with that and the same
thing you know I've written about how
there's such an emphasis for for girls
to be like boys now
I saw you tweet about babies yeah babies
and underline that is a sexism that you
know says that girls need to be like
boys in order to be equal or worthy of
respect and no one's talking about that
where people are just saying yeah for
sure let's just you know tell girls that
they have to be the same as boys and
women have to
same as men yeah so the article you're
referring to it there was this piece I
think it was in Newsweek that these
parents are raising their twins as
babies th ey babies babies because and
they're gonna let them pick their gender
mm-hmm and it's like you're gonna create
more psychological problems than you
were trying to hide them from most
likely I think yeah and it goes back to
biology again and hormonal exposure in
utero
yeah I think it's great that he might
have been NBC News I think not me okay
yeah yeah but I think there are a couple
outlets that were so excited about this
and the whole that's with it without was
why I wrote about it not because of the
thing you know these parents can do
whatever they want that's what I
followed up with immediately after
parents can do whatever they want and
then when the children are of age they
can either decide my parents were crazy
or not right this is on the parents
right and all that but that wasn't the
issue for me it was that the way these
headlines are always written it's like
that this it was like this is the new
thing and the implicit piece of that is
you better do this yeah to be a good
parent
and tolerant parent to be a progressive
parent and that is open-minded person
and that to me is the danger here
not the little isolated case necessarily
of these people that are doing something
that's an outlier thing yeah and and the
thing is I've heard stories now where
people are terrified of giving their
daughters dolls and which is what's
really funny is you have some of these
really progressive parents who raise
their girls they only have
gender-neutral toys or they give them
boys toys and then the girl obviously
goes to school and sees girl typical
toys and wants to play for them and the
parents are horrified and they think oh
this is the patriarchy coming in the
return of the Patriots just biology and
we shouldn't be afraid of that and we
shouldn't we shouldn't shame girls for
wanting to be female typical yeah but
this is why when people say I think to a
bunch of us that are in this space oh
you guys are overstating what this thing
is it's just a bunch of angry activists
or whatever it's like we've seen it in
fact academia we addressed already we've
seen it in fact the home and how you're
supposed to raise your kids even just
thinking about this now it's like I
think I'd read something on this and if
not there's definite proof of it that
Disney made a decision along the way now
that they have Star Wars and Marvel that
Star Wars
was gonna be more marketing to girls and
marvel was going to be the boys thing
now I'm a big Star Wars guy and I would
see these commercials and it was all
girl you know girls in the ships and
girls with the lightsabers like I have
no problem with that
obviously rave a leading character and
last one is a girl it's all good that
girls can do it I'm up but but pushing
marketing on them seems odd to me and
and although I'm sure there are many
girl girls out there that want to be
Jedi there's obviously more boys so the
way that we even mark it and I suspect
they're marketing in a way that's
hurting their bottom line in the name of
tolerance in the name of what I don't
know yeah so I mean how did the boys
feel about that right right so you're
gonna get this odd thing then when
eventually it if they're enough
marketing boys are gonna want to play
with the girl thing and then feel weird
about it
god that's messed it too much time they
do have too much time on their hands
yeah I just say let kids do what they
want and acknowledge that as long as you
give them free choices you probably
won't have too much say at the end the
day but at least you know they they'll
be happy yeah
is there anything else that you're
researching at the moment or that's been
on your mind that that we haven't
covered the only thing I would say is so
with wrong speak we are gonna be
launching our site we just launched our
first season yeah last month so we spoke
with James Tim or Lindsey Shepard we
also did an episode on rapid onset
gender dysphoria so it's this phenomenon
of adolescent girls who were suddenly
saying they're transgender even though
they've had no previous signs of gender
dysphoria and actually their problems
have nothing to do with gender so so
what are the problems that's just
societal stuff or pressure or wanting
attention or all of the above
usually autism as well so they either
will be diagnosed by a mental
professional but the person will say I
can't say that I have to you know affirm
your child's gender because they can
otherwise get a lot of trouble and lose
their jobs that they don't really you
repeat that again Kevin right so that
they will lose their jobs if they don't
know but they they have to affirm
they're late they can yeah
they have to clinicians nowadays have to
affirm these kids if a child says
they're transgender you have to they'll
lose their jobs otherwise so so
technically a therapist
or a clinician could feel that this is
some other issue going on nothing but
they have to actually affirm what the
child says yeah the parents and in all
the documents yeah because they will
lose their jobs they're terrified and so
in Toronto what happened but what the
Preston case was my colleague Kenneth
sucker
I had a clinic where he saw gender
dysphoria and people said that he was
practicing conversion therapy he was not
so conversion therapy I do not stand for
it's trying to turn gay children
straight but sexual orientation is not
the same thing as gender so gender and
young children is flexible and it
becomes more stable with age so when he
when patients would come to him and say
you know I want to be the opposite sex
he would say okay what's this when you
say gender is taxable you don't mean the
amount of genders you mean the female
that you have related to gender sex I
just want to be clear so if you have an
example you've been using if you have a
little boy who says he's a girl he will
likely be a gay man and he will likely
grow to be comfortable in his male
gender identity so for 99% of us our
biological sex is our gender yeah this
this thing it's it's a real monster yeah
there's a lot of misinformation out
there so know what I was saying with my
colleague his clinic got shut down he
wasn't doing anything unethical but
because of that it set this chill across
the field now clinicians do not do not
want to have the same thing happen to
them because activists will go after
them yeah so there's no one really
practicing or any one sort of thought of
his legitimate that's practicing
conversion therapy anymore is there I
hope not and all the science is against
it like the that it just never worked
like it was just something that I guess
sort of twisted ideologue was practicing
not using real evidence or science and
yeah I mean they just fizzled out
basically yeah I do think there are some
practitioners who are still doing it not
I wouldn't call them legitimate which it
makes me very uncomfortable
when I see that but yeah definitely
sexual orientation is biological its
genetic
it can't be changed so conversion
therapy is completely useless yeah well
I'm glad we got there at least I think I
think most people won't be angry at you
on that one well I guess maybe some
people on the right maybe might be angry
maybe but you know I'm all about
presenting the data and speaking to
facts and the science and standing up
for sex research whether it infuriates
people on the left or the right yeah
science facts reason pretty much pretty
much all but all sort of package within
within the free speech thing yeah can I
call you a member of the intellectual
dark web please do I don't know that I
have that power but I'm gonna go back to
the clubhouse later get me a membership
yeah yeah you know we have to vote on it
I can be a white man some days yeah oh
right that was the thing it was like
they you know whatever all these idiots
that are writing all these nonsensical
pieces about it's all white men and it's
like they're a bunch of us that are not
white but I mean they call I've been
called a white supremacist I've been
called a Nazi so you know that's the
level that we're at right now and they
have nothing else so I think it's a good
sign in a weird way it absolutely is a
good time well it's been a pleasure I'm
so glad that we finally got to do this
it's so much fun yeah we will we will do
I sense these issues are not going away
so we're gonna have to do this again all
right very good
for more on Debra you can follow her on
Twitter it's at Debra so
[Music]